[Música]
y el método tradicional de elaboración
de una vacuna el utilizado por louis
pasteur consiste en inyectar total o
parcialmente una forma atenuada o
inactiva del virus
primero se replica en el laboratorio y
se purifica una vez que se inyecta la
preparación las células identifican el
patógeno y producen anticuerpos capaces
de neutralizar lo el cuerpo recordará
cómo combatirlo en caso de futuras
infecciones este es el método elegido
por el laboratorio chino sinovac biotech
la nueva generación de vacunas de adn a
rn es diferente aquí ya no se trata de
inyectar el virus como tal sino el rn
mensajero
es la instrucción genética la que ordena
la creación de las espéculas esas
proteínas presentes en la superficie del
virus que le dan forma de corona después
de haber inyectado directamente esta
información genética dentro de las
células humanas la leerán como una
receta y ellos mismos producirán estas
espículas afortunadamente inofensivas
para los humanos sin embargo el sistema
inmunológico los reconocerá como
extraños y producirá anticuerpos el día
que el organismo se enfrenta a las
espéculas reales sabrá cómo neutralizar
las estas vacunas que son más sencillas
y rápidas de producir deben almacenarse
a baja temperatura en esta misma familia
de vacunas las vacunas de vectores
virales aquí el material genético se
transporta a la célula por medio de otro
virus para desencadenar una respuesta
inmune más fuerte este es el método
utilizado en particular por astrazéneca
y muchos otros laboratorios
[Música]